[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
nuestro invitado del día de hoy es
Jonathan Powell quien fue el ex jefe de
gabinete del Primer Ministro británico
Tony Blair y más conocido como el
arquitecto del acuerdo de paz del
viernes santo del acuerdo belfas firmado
hace 25 años y que terminó la violencia
del conflicto conocido como de travels y
trajo además Paz política Irlanda del
Norte aquí en el Reino Unido señor
Powell Gracias por estar con nosotros en
France 24 Me gustaría empezar por
preguntarle Cuáles creen usted son las
lecciones más importantes después de 25
años del acuerdo para los uninionistas
los republicanos y el público en general
aquí en el Reino Unido
la lección más importante que me queda
de los últimos 25 años es la importancia
de la paciencia y centrarse en la
implementación del acuerdo si se llega a
un acuerdo histórico como el acuerdo del
viernes este no arregla todo
inmediatamente hay que trabajar más duro
para llevarlo a la práctica nos tomó 9
años después de firmar el acuerdo de
viernes Santo en 1998 establecer las
nuevas instituciones con Ian page lee
como Primer Ministro y Martínez como
viceprimer ministro lo que suele ocurrir
con Los acuerdos por ejemplo con Los
acuerdos de oslo en medio oriente es que
se llega a un gran acuerdo pero nunca se
implementan y SS problema en Colombia se
firmó el acuerdo con las Farc pero su
implementación ha sido muy muy difícil
desde el cambio de gobierno tras la
salida del presidente Santos creo que lo
que he aprendido es que si se quiere que
un acuerdo funcione no solo hay que
pensar en el documento que se firma ese
documento no hace que las partes confíen
más en el otro ese documento existe
porque no se Confía en el otro lo que
hay que hacer es ponerlo en práctica dar
los pasos que se prometieron Y entonces
poco a poco se podrá construir una paz
duradera en la que de verdad no haya más
violencia y se pueda volver a la
política normal
usted ha dicho que tanto el acuerdo como
el conflicto en Irlanda del Norte son
sui generis Por qué a veces la gente se
toma las cosas demasiado literalmente
por ejemplo en el país Vasco en España
algunas personas tomaron el acuerdo de
Irlanda del Norte casi como si fuera un
modelo que pudiera ser copiado y
aplicado al país Vasco el conflicto del
país Vasco era muy diferente al de
Irlanda del Norte el conflicto de
Colombia era muy diferente Pero hay
lecciones interesantes que aprender
aunque no sea el mismo acuerdo aunque no
sea el mismo conflicto hay elecciones
sobre lo que funciona y lo que no en
estas negociaciones Y a lo que he
dedicado mi vida desde que dejé el
gobierno es precisamente a intentar
difundir esas lecciones ver si podemos
compartirla sin que haya negociaciones
en otros lugares asegurarnos de que
tengan éxito después de 25 años en su
opinión cree usted que el acuerdo ha
sido exitosamente implementado y es Sí
pero no iba a ser un cuento de hadas
cuando se firma un acuerdo la gente no
vive feliz para siempre todavía tenemos
graves problemas en Irlanda del Norte
tenemos problemas de incertidumbre e
inestabilidad tenemos problemas de
violencia que también siguen recorriendo
así que yo no haría como si todo fuera
perfecto en Irlanda del norte de hecho
si uno va a Irlanda del Norte Ahora verá
que hay más muros de la paz en belfas
separando comunidades que los que había
cuando firmamos los acuerdos del viernes
santo pero esencialmente lo que pasa en
el acuerdo del viernes Santo le puso fin
al conflicto honora Irlandés estuvimos
en una guerra civil por más de 30 años
una guerra que dejó cientos e incluso
miles de Muertos eso no se acabó nunca
volveremos ahí Entonces desde ese punto
de vista tuvimos éxito acabamos con el
conflicto y tenemos un sistema de poder
compartido que funcionan puedo
preguntarle cuál fue su impresión sobre
su primera impresión sobre los líderes
históricos de Lira Jerry Adams y Marty
Martínez especialmente porque su padre
fue herido por el ira y su hermano
estuvo en la lista de muerte de esa
guerrilla de esa organización terrorista
cuando conocí a Jerry Adams y Martin
Martínez creo que fue en octubre de 1997
no me sentí muy cómodo con ellos como
usted mencionó le había a mi padre en
1940 y lo había herido mi hermano mayor
que trabajaba para thatcher estuvo en su
lista de muerte durante ocho años
entonces cuando los conocí me negué a
darles la mano en retrospectiva me
arrepiento de no haberlo hecho fue una
tontería Tony Blair que estaba conmigo
si les dio la mano y eso fue lo correcto
Aunque inmediatamente después se
enfrentó a las protestas de la gente de
Irlanda del Norte por haber dado la mano
asesinos era algo complicado pero poco
después de esa reunión Martínez me llamó
y me preguntó si iría de incógnito a
derry una ciudad de Irlanda del Norte y
me pidió que no le dijera a la policía
ni al ejército que simplemente fuera le
pregunté a Tony Blair y me dijo sí eres
prescindible porque no vas entonces me
subí a un avión viaje hasta belfas y
tomé un taxi hasta derry me paré en una
esquina y llegaron dos hombres con las
cabezas rapadas me metieron en la parte
de atrás de un taxi me dieron vueltas
por la ciudad para que no supiera donde
estaba después me sacaron del taxi y me
dejaron frente a una casa Fui a la casa
golpeé y Martín abrió la puerta con
muletas e hizo un chiste muy malo sobre
un castigo que tenía Lira que consistía
en dispararle a la gente en las rodillas
los tobillos los codos y nos sentamos en
esa casa durante tres horas que era un
lugar seguro era de una mujer que se
había ido y la había dejado desocupada y
no avanzamos nada pero entendí que
independientemente de lo que pensara
sobre Adams y Martínez
independientemente de lo que pensara que
eran unos terroristas si queríamos
alcanzar la paz teníamos que construir
confianza había que ir a su territorio
tomar riesgos compartidos Y esa es la
lección que me ha servido para tratar de
alcanzar la paz en otro lugares
hemos ido a Abel fase en el cubrimiento
en France 24 y aunque no hay violencia
las comunidades republicanas y
unionistas no se integran que queda
pendiente por hacer
es cierto que las comunidades siguen
estando bastante separadas en Irlanda
del Norte El acuerdo de paz en sí no
normalizó la política Por así decirlo la
gente sigue votando según criterios
sectarios votando por partidos católicos
o por protestantes cuando firmamos el
acuerdo de paz David trimble el líder de
los unionistas me dijo que esperaba que
la política se desarrollara como en
Inglaterra que tuviéramos un partido de
izquierda y otro de derecha Pero eso no
sucedió seguimos con los partidos
sectarios pero lo que está ocurriendo
ahora es alentador si analizamos las
últimas elecciones el partido que más
está creciendo es el partido alianza que
no es ni católico ni protestante los
unionistas y los republicanos siguen
estando presentes pero ahora el centro
está creciendo Y eso también lo vimos en
el censo que tuvimos el año pasado en ir
del Norte que mostró que la población
con más crecimiento casi la mayoría en
el país son los que dicen que no son ni
católicos ni protestantes ni unionistas
ni republicanos entonces vemos que hay
un centro que está creciendo en la
política de Irlanda del Norte Esto va a
lograr normalizar poco a poco Irlanda
del Norte va a lograr que la política
sea más como la del resto del mundo
el gobierno británico acaba de presentar
una ley al parlamento que palabras más
palabras menos Busca traer amnistía para
los crímenes cometidos durante el
período que se llama the travels las
víctimas del conflicto no quieren esa
ley Cuál es su opinión sobre esto
el gobierno está intentando abordar un
problema real y el problema en Irlanda
del Norte es que no hemos podido escapar
del pasado en la mayoría de los países
en los que se firma un acuerdo de paz
existe un proceso de verdad y
Reconciliación por ejemplo en Colombia
existe el sistema de justicia
transicional en el que tanto militares
como los guerrilleros terroristas tienen
que cumplir penas de cárcel aunque no
muy largas en términos de justicia
retributiva nunca pudimos hacer eso en
Irlanda del norte de hecho creamos una
comisión al final de nuestro periodo en
el gobierno para ver cómo se podía
trazar una línea en la historia volvimos
después de haber dejado el gobierno y
vimos que no se habían hecho
recomendaciones porque ni los
republicanos ni los uninionistas querían
hacerlo el gobierno insiste en que ha
estado buscando una forma de alcanzar la
reconciliación que hasta ahora no ha
funcionado y están tratando de resolver
ese problema la forma en que lo hicieron
No fue para nada acertada intentaron
imponerlo unilateralmente no lo
consultaron con las víctimas ni con las
familias de las víctimas no lo
consultaron con los partidos políticos
como resultado todas las víctimas y
todos partidos políticos de Irlanda del
Norte se opusieron totalmente a lo que
pretendían hacer y partiendo de ahí les
va a ser muy difícil avanzar están
tratando de aprobar una ley pero creo
que será complicado lograr que la gente
la acepte
Cuál es el efecto del brexit en el
acuerdo de paz de 1998 el brexit siempre
iba a perturbar mucho el proceso de
Irlanda del Norte algunos de nosotros lo
advertimos durante el referendo del
brexit en 2016 entre ellos Tony Blair y
John Mayer ambos arquitectos del proceso
de Paz El problema es que al salir de la
Unión Europea abandonamos el mercado
único europeo abandonamos la unión
aduanera y tiene que haber una frontera
en algún lugar el brexit pretendía que
no hubiera una frontera que se hiciera
por arte de magia con una tecnología que
todavía no existe Pero tiene que haber
una frontera si la frontera se hubiera
puesto en la isla de Irlanda entre el
norte y el sur habría sido muy
perjudicial para el proceso de Paz
Porque habría reintroducido toda la
cuestión de la identidad el objetivo del
acuerdo del viernes Santo era intentar
de la política del veneno de la
identidad tanto si eras católico como
protestante y si se hubiera vuelto a
poner una frontera se habría reabierto
este problema porque la gente ya no
podría vivir en Irlanda del Norte y
sentirse irlandesa o irlandesa y
británica y todo el objetivo era que se
pudiera sentir como quisiera y que no
fuera algo impuesto por lo tanto la
frontera no puede estar entre Irlanda
del norte y del sur y el único lugar de
la frontera donde podría estar es en el
mar de Irlanda al final Boris Johnson
aceptó que la frontera estuviera en el
mar de Irlanda sabía que iba a
perjudicar la posición de los unionistas
afectar su identidad porque ellos
quieren ser parte de Reino Unido Tan
pronto como se pusiera una frontera ahí
sería difícil que se siguieran sintiendo
Así luego Johnson pretendió que no era
así lo cual era ridículo intentó
desafiar a la Unión Europea en Casos
legales incumpliendo las leyes por
suerte ya no es Primer Ministro y por
suerte el nuevo Primer Ministro Richie
sunak está intentando solucionar el
problema aceptando el protocolo pero
encontrando la manera de eliminar las
dificultades prácticas de su aplicación
y me complace decir que tuvo éxito ahora
estamos esperando saber si el partido
unionista democrático el mayor de los
partidos unionistas lo va a aceptar y
Volver al gobierno de Irlanda del Norte
Esperamos que lo hagan pero no tomarán
una decisión hasta final de
meslum McDonald que es la jefa del
chinfeine del partido republicano ha
dicho que la asamblea de stormont es el
símbolo del acuerdo de paz de 1998 pero
está en peligro porque no hay ejecutivo
hace más de un año Cuál es su opinión
usted está de acuerdo sí es toda una
paradoja los unionistas son quienes
históricamente Siempre han insistido en
la existencia de starman en tener un
gobierno para Irlanda del Norte y no Un
gobierno para toda Irlanda eso es lo que
querían pero eso fue creada a Irlanda
del Norte en 1922 Así que resulta
paradójico que ahora sean ellos quienes
bloqueen la formación de un gobierno en
y es muy preocupante porque a menos que
vuelvan a entrar lo que va a pasar Es
que la gente va a pensar cada vez más en
la posibilidad la reunificación de
Irlanda y eso va a incrementar los
miedos de los unionistas porque si no
hay gobierno en esto tiene que haber
algún gobierno en la isla de Irlanda y
eso dificulta mucho su posición me
preocupa que si deciden no volver al
gobierno a finales de mes perdamos
stormont y todo este tema de la
reunificación en Irlanda cobre más
relevancia y sea más difícil
políticamente pero realmente espero que
Jeffrey donaldson el líder del partido
unionista democrático acepte Volver al
gobierno Y entonces podamos celebrar con
éxito El Aniversario 25 y todo siga
adelante con un gobierno en funciones
usted ha pasado
más de 20 años hablando con terroristas
tratando de acabar los conflictos
armados alrededor del mundo y uno de
ellos fue el proceso de paz entre las
FARC y el gobierno de Colombia después
de siete años de la implementación del
acuerdo cuáles son sus opiniones el
conflicto de las FARC fue terrible para
el pueblo colombiano el número de
muertos los años que duró los
desplazados los daños fue terrible mucho
más que en Irlanda del Norte muchas más
víctimas creo que el presidente Santos
se merecía totalmente el premio Nobel
por haber hecho posible la paz en
Colombia puso todo su capital político
para alcanzar la paz y su reelección
para el segundo mandato en resolver el
conflicto fue excelente cuando logramos
el acuerdo tengo que reconocer que la
implementación no ha tenido el éxito que
se hubiera querido y eso es lo que pasa
a veces cuando el presidente que
implementó el acuerdo de paz Es
reemplazado por un presidente de un
partido político diferente porque el
nuevo presidente no está tan
comprometido ni tan interesado en el
acuerdo de paz en el caso del presidente
Duque su partido se había opuesto al
acuerdo en el referendo intentaron que
no fuera aceptado el expresidente no
estaba comprometido con este Por eso
creo que la implementación no ha tenido
éxito y espero que el gobierno del
presidente Petro el nuevo presidente de
Colombia Se Centre en implementar
plenamente ese acuerdo así como intentar
alcanzar la paz total entre todos los
demás grupos la implementación ha sido
bastante complicada en Colombia pero
Confío en que ahora tengamos una
oportunidad real de implementarlo
plenamente y de que la violencia llegue
a su fin de una vez por todas en
Colombia Debería ser un gran alivio para
los colombianos
Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros en France 24 y ustedes por
favor sigan con nosotros con toda
nuestra programación en Francia 24 y
Francia 24 punto com
[Música]